[Music]
gwen stefani and blake shelton celebrate
their first valentine's day together as
husband and wife
sharing never-before-seen footage from
their wedding day this is romance around
here of course on monday the 52-year-old
singer shared this clip from her july
nuptials on instagram that's gwen and
blake flashing their pearly whites in
their wedding attire alongside gwen's
seven-year-old son apollo
[Music]
you've already
gwen captioned the sweet post quote the
stars the moon my whole world
and if that song sounds familiar it's
because it is
you and me
are a blessing
and all we gotta do is say amen
it's the song blake wrote and performed
for gwen on their big day called we can
reach the stars
i was only trying to impress gwen i
think i'm his biggest fan the no doubt
singer also shared this adorable montage
with her beau serving classic gwen and
blake cuteness
i feel like you don't like me anymore i
don't
i love you as for blake he posted his
own throwback wedding snap in honor of
valentine's day that's the gods country
singer with his leading lady standing at
the altar which he sweetly captioned
quote i'm the luckiest man alive happy
valentine's day gwen stefani i love you
it's very emotional of course the love
birds first met on the set of the voice
in 2015. it ended up being
the greatest moment of my life you know
so it's just it's amazing it truly is
and tied the knot in july at blake's
oklahoma ranch sometimes i just feel
like i'm in a dream back in july blake
sat down with ellen degeneres and opened
up about their big day joking that he
just let his then bride-to-be take the
reins when it came to wedding planning
even when he got criticized in the press
for it one point i was saying you know
in an interview like we're letting when
you know gwen just do
whatever she wants for the wedding and
then some writer wrote well oh look you
know the ladies he's already a lazy
deadbeat husband but the truth is
i am
but of course it was her it was all her
idea her her vision and
all i had to do was drink and kiss gwen
stefani i mean my god it's
the greatest gig i ever had
their good pal and the voice host carson
daly officiated the nuptials and opened
up about the emotional day shortly after
their ideas
at the wedding gwen starts and she wrote
this i mean like since i was a little
girl blah blah blah and she crushes not
a dry eye in the church
we are all like and it was so perfect
that i said blake when she was done i'm
like top that buddy
well turns out blake held his own and
surprised gwen with that song i
mentioned earlier
and blake starts by saying you know
gwen's always giving me a hard time
about not writing enough songs yeah so i
wrote a song and he sings her a song
while he's crying that he wrote
specifically for her and not a dry eye
in the house oh my gosh and that was
really a highlight
and months later it's safe to say their
love still has us crying are your eyes
watery i yes
[Music]
you